that's not the plan
yeah you uh you pride yourself on not
necessarily I saw you correct somebody
in terms of like not making quote
unquote West Coast rap genre
stop a record store sometimes you'll see
West Coast rap 100 that's a genre I'm
saying I'm not the genre that was like
some characters
for that time we all characters so I'm
not saying that to take nothing from
them but those people were from places
that aren't even close to where I'm from
you know what I'm saying they're not
even from the state that I'm from but a
lot of them not even just like at the
end of the day I'm telling the story of
you know going up Wilmington to going
down Rosecrans I'm going from Wise
Compton and Gardena like the regions
that I really know you know I'm painting
that picture you know what I'm saying so
I just
try to show people like you know the
reason I don't jump on that is because
I'm a real trap [__] too right you know
what I'm saying I'm a real out of town
[__] too I'm a real you know what I'm
saying I still be with my peoples from
other states you know what I'm saying
well you described your last day before
turning yourself in as to me a perfect
example of what you were able to help do
and that was Bridge
a whole world of like you mentioned pump
and Uzi right and shout out to Desto dub
who actually helped a lot of this too
but just there's like a whole generation
of kids that were looking for like a an
artist like yourself like Draco like
Shoreline to kind of like not
necessarily you know like you said be
honest it's like it's like six or seven
artists that's out right now I won't I
won't just say their name in case it
makes it I want to make it seem like
it's a flex on right but they'll give me
my you know respect on that [__] of me
like opening up
a door where where artists could be
different or you could be more melodic
but you could talk about what you want
to talk about
or like even like the producer there's a
lot of people that make their own beef
soup or people that just only make beats
uh Inspire producers just like producing
never been or you know what I'm saying
just like some of my bigger songs sweet
lady you know I'm saying or people
you know what I'm saying just seeing
like those are real people in the songs
and [__] I just let people say you know
tell your own story I'm saying be
yourself if you like whatever you like
you know what I'm saying
um while you're locked up versus pops
off
and I've been saying this you and RJ did
the first verses ever
yeah I remember the individual I did it
with I remember I had thought of that
idea
and it was jumping I remember me and DJ
head were like uh I feel like that's
always a touchy situation I don't wanna
answer none to make it feel like
we restarted on disrespect no no I'm not
even talking about that specific
situation I'm just saying like it's just
kind of crazy to think like so I'll just
try to stay talking about me that was my
situation that was a very successful
peaceful event that you know we always
meet me and had always talk we're like
but that Loki was the first verses that
ever happened like you know what I'm
saying like yeah but I missed out I mean
I didn't do any paperwork because that
was the no I created Novo and you guys
did it in Orange County right yeah yeah
I didn't do no paperwork to say that I
created that and then um
um I was telling uh Picasso like hey man
I probably should trademark this because
ain't nobody never did this he was like
well it kind of with Drake versus Lil
Wayne I guess where they said it like
that but they from the same team I'm
saying this is like something that could
even turn into violence and I and I um
I will probably just rather get the
credit for doing some positive it was
something they're just saying that I was
the first to create that because I
didn't I didn't I mean
the concept is similar but
no but it was it was dope to see that
positive outcome of that because you
know what ended up happening but I just
thought I just thought it was though
like again you're an innovator man so I
wish I did do some paperwork on that
would have been making some money for
sure I did not missed out on that how
crazy was it dealing with Covey while
being incarcerated having coveted while
incarcerated was horrible and then I
feel like I still don't believe the same
and [__] so you had it could you taste
could you smell it yeah I could taste
this smell I'm greedy I'ma still taste
that food I got to eat but
my body was feeling like I got hit with
like some
some heaviest [__] like I got into an
accident or something like God damn so
hit you and I was wondering the covet
doubt is like that's not no real [__]
and then you got y'all out there going
through weird [__] yeah they're telling
me it's like a ghost and I'm like that's
what y'all get I'm out here in the ghost
town yeah everybody was kind of in their
especially La I'm sure you heard La was
crazy there was no traffic which is like
you could get to wherever you wanted
actually
I don't know make I don't know bro there
was Zero traffic you could get to like
Orange County in like 20 minutes I mean
if I'd have been flying in that ass it
was crazy bro like and then the homeless
shape just blew up like I don't know if
I mean there was always homeless [__]
you know obviously but now it's like
wherever you're at oh yeah it's them
encampments it's turning up in La man
it's oh yeah you'd be in a nice area
sometimes yeah like Venice Beach during
the pandemic
I'll never be in L.A like that no more
it's just
I like experience in life you know what
I'm saying I like to see new things
I didn't did LA of course I understand
what comes with being like
one of the first people living this life
from you know any of the areas I came up
in yeah
so I walk late I don't really come to
L.A I know where I'm at I know what I'm
what it's about